За даними Федерального статистичного відомства Німеччини, станом на 2019 рік
у країні з населенням близько 80 мільйонів осіб налічувалося 426 закладів вищої освіти.
До таких у ФРН зараховують університети, а також педагогічні, мистецькі,
професійні, управлінські й теологічні вищі школи - Fachhochschulen.
Статус університету в Німеччині наразі мають 106 закладів вищої освіти.
Решта - вищі школи.
Торік до всіх німецьких вишів вступили понад два мільйони 800 тисяч студентів.
Хоча і університети, і вищі школи надають вищу освіту,
ще донедавна другі негласно вважалися менш престижними.
Головна відмінність університету від вищої школи - можливість отримання
наукового ступеню та проведення наукових досліджень.
Останніми роками ситуація змінюється: орієнтовані на дослідницьку роботу
і теоретичне спрямування університетські програми
дедалі частіше прив’язуються до практичних потреб.
А у вищих школах усе частіше обговорюють можливості наукових досліджень
та отримання наукових ступенів.
Дедалі більше абітурієнтів (близько 40 відсотків) обирають вищі школи,
адже отримання конкретної фахової спеціалізації підвищує шанси
на успішне працевлаштування на німецькому ринку праці.
Престиж університетів не в останню чергу зумовлений
тривалою традицією вищої освіти в Німеччині - їй уже понад 600 років.
Найстарішим у країні, а також одним із найстаріших у Європі,
є Гейдельберзький університет, заснований у 1386 році.
Це провідний заклад вищої освіти у галузі медицини, зокрема, онкології.
Серед перших німецьких університетів - засновані у 14-15 століттях університети
Кельна, Ерфурта, Фрайбурга, Майнца, Мюнхена, Тріра та Вюрцбурга.
Усі вони - державні.
Серед найновіших німецьких вишів -
здебільшого професійні вищі школи Fachhochschulen.
Наприклад, засновані у 2017 році в Берліні та Ізерлоні вищі школи,
що надають освіту в галузі комп'ютерних наук і технологій.
Обидва заклади приватні.
Втім, серед вищих шкіл, відкритих у 2000-х роках, є й чимало державних:
це означає, що уряди федеральних земель побачили потребу у фахівцях
із певною спеціалізацією та виділили на їхню освіту гроші.
У минулі 10 років, підрахували у Федеральному статистичному відомстві,
в Німеччині відкрилося 45 нових закладів вищої освіти.
Кілька вишів за цей же час припинили своє існування.
Серед понад чотирьох сотень німецьких університетів і вищих шкіл -
приблизно 120 - приватні. З них менше 20ти - університети.
Пояснюється це тим, що статус "університет" у Німеччині є, так би мовити, захищеним.
Щоб його отримати, заклад освіти має пройти складну тривалу процедуру акредитації
та підтвердити відповідність низці вимог.
Приміром, виш має надавати дійсно універсальну освіту
та мати здатність проводити повноцінні наукові дослідження.
Крім того, є низка специфічних вимог, пов'язаних із навчальними програмами,
кваліфікацією і навіть процесом залучення професорсько-викладацького складу.
Державні заклади вищої освіти отримують 75% фінансування від держави,
зокрема, від земельних урядів. Це так зване гарантоване базове фінансування.
Решту грошей виші можуть залучити або з інших бюджетних джерел
- через програми підтримки досліджень та розвитку, або завдяки приватному фінансуванню.
Прикладом залучення приватних грошей може бути, скажімо,
розробка у виші конкретних ліків або технологій на замовлення певної компанії.
Із 2006 року німецькі університети можуть отримати додаткове держфінансування,
виборовши статус "найкращого університету"  - німецькою Exzellenz-Universität.
У рамках "Стратегії переваги" раз на 7 років журі з політиків та вчених
обирає найбільш інноваційні проекти та виші, які максимально сприяють розвиткові науки.
Переможцям дістається не лише престижне звання, а й гроші
- від 10 до 28 мільйонів євро на рік.
У 2019-му звання "найкращих" отримали університети у Гамбурзі, Аахені,
Бонні, Дрездені, Гейдельберзі, Карлсруе, Констанці та Тюбінгені.
Німецький уряд сподівається, що ця програма допоможе вишам
піднятися і в міжнародних рейтингах.
Поки університети з ФРН добряче поступаються вишам зі США, Британії й Канади,
хоча й посідають провідні позиції у переліках найбільш інноваційних університетів світу.
А ще престиж німецьких університетів можна виміряти кількістю нобелівських лауреатів,
які вийшли з їхніх стін: найбільше їх у Технічного університету Мюнхена - 16.
В університетів Гейдельберга і Геттінгена - по 14 нобелівських лауреатів.